Jurassic world Dominion has now released
a much awaited prologue the one that was
seen by just a Selected Few before the
Fast and Furious 9 movie in the cinemas
but this prologue is different it is
extended and has quite a few new
dinosaurs introduced into the franchise
here in this video we are going to count
them down and also analyze as to how the
Giganotosaurus defeated the T-Rex quite
so easily without breaking a sweat plus
will Rexy get her revenge in the movie
so here in the prologue which is set 65
million years ago we get to see a total
of 10 dinosaur species in detail
starting with the gigantic
dreadnaughters this Beast was almost 16
meters or 52 feet tall from the feet to
the top of the head when stunning erect
erect get it anyway they were seen in a
swarm working majestically probably the
biggest dinos during that age then a few
seconds into the prologue we see the
gigantic flying puzzle Cola sweeping
down on a dead carcass and chasing away
small pterosaurs which may be belong to
the teradonia group
the crystal colors are as tall as
giraffes with a 36 feet wingspan
then we shift to a shot of the armored
ankylosaurus which by now are quite
familiar dinos and was seen in the last
two movies as well they were happily
grazing with no idea something big was
coming their way maybe a big rock from
outer space but thankfully it was not
seen here in this trailer prologue next
we see a new entry in the form of the
active new oviraptor heavily feathered
ass they should have been which makes it
an up-to-date precise description of how
raptors should look like then we get to
see a herd of nazoceratops on the Move
probably on a migration route like
wildebeest in the Serengeti Plains
surprisingly we also see a small
Tyrannosaur not a giant T-rex but the
smaller cousin called The Morris
intrepidus and it is feeding off the
stuck meat in between the teeth of a
gigantic apex predator which we see as
none other than the Giganotosaurus the
Morris intrepidus holds a place in the
food chain akin to those of small birds
that clean the meat of of crocodiles we
also see an Iguanodon briefly looking up
at the giant Giganotosaurus As It
prepares to square off against another
rival which is of a different species
the Tyrannosaurus Rex none other than
the original Rexy the original you may
ask well I'll explain it to you in a bit
so in the confrontation the T-Rex and
the Giganotosaurus kinda had this short
face off with them walking around like a
couple of cowboys before a duel and then
boom They smash into one another and in
a short battle
the Giganotosaurus got the upper hand
well maybe because the T-Rex has tiny
hands but seriously the gigolo thesaurus
made short work of the T-Rex which was
kind of upsetting as many of the dino
versus dino videos here in YouTube
always mostly have the T-Rex winning the
fight but the question is why did the
T-Rex fall so easily
here are three reasons as to why the
original Rexy lost the battle yes as I
said before this was Rexy 65 million
years in the past I say so because in
the end of the battle we see a mosquito
sucking the blood of the defeated Dino
which would serve as the Genesis of the
new ones seen in the present times it
was these genes that we used for the
Jurassic Park T-Rex that was taken from
this individual mosquito that was later
stuck in Amber and preserved for
millions of years so back to the reasons
firstly as we can clearly see the
Giganotosaurus was bigger secondly the
T-Rex was maybe of an older age and
didn't get the killing blow with its
powerful bite force and lastly the
reason why it died in the Battle was
because it fell down from a significant
height imagine 8 to 9 tons of meat and
bones falling from a height that means
shared bones ribs muscular tear and a
shock to the spine so will she get her
revenge in the movie well clearly the
movie is going to set up in a way that
an eventual rematch between these two
dinos will take place somewhere down the
line we have seen a leaked image of a
giganotosaurus being cloned and this
might be the same one as seen in the
prologue so with the T-Rex losing to
Spinosaurus in Jurassic Park 3 almost
losing it to the indominus Rex but
luckily with the help of blue and the
mosasaurus the indorex Was Defeated and
now with it losing to the Giganotosaurus
in the prologue I think it would be
poetic if it won the last fight in this
Trilogy which is hopefully the last
Jurassic movie as we all say all good
things come to an end and also that
means that we have come to the end of
the video so hit that like button for
support and subscribe to be a part of
the Mind Q family and also hit that Bell
icon for regular updates on new monster
content right here on this channel till
the next one take care fam